before we get started and and before we
start talking about devstack ops when we
talk about anything I thought we could
like talk about something a little more
historic something that's been that's it
happened a long time ago and I wanted to
originally call this talk like a tale of
money chaos and woe
then kind of changed it up a little bit
but in the day in the year of 1896
almost to the day with this this coming
Sunday is gonna be anniversary there was
there's this man who came up with this
idea that they were going to ram these
two trains together as a demolition
experience so this is a William crush
William crush is a ticket agent for the
Missouri Kansas Texas railway often
referred to the Katie back in the day
and William crush was just a passenger
agent and and they the Katie knew that
they want to expand their their
influence and their their reach across
the state of Texas and they needed some
promotion to do that and crushed had
kind of been watching the newspapers
he'd seen some other things going on in
the in the world and and that was that
was interesting he saw these other
people trying to run run trains together
and he knew that they had some spare
engines laying around that they were
gonna be retired so he thought he
thought well why don't we why don't we
get those and and through this
promotional purpose like we're gonna
we're gonna jam these trains together so
it's gonna be like a demolition derby
but for trains and this was not you know
like I said it's not wasn't the first
time that that anybody had come up with
this idea but this is the first time
that I think that we saw it be
successful sort of in a way but the idea
was happened in Ohio several times but
they struggled with the idea because
they were like try to charge tickets but
like you're Raymond to trains together
so you really have to block off a big
area and so people were like climbing up
in trees to watch it and sometimes they
wouldn't even end up ramming the trains
together because of the financers are
like okay we don't have enough ticket
sales for this so crushes innovation the
whole thing was the freemium model he's
like we're just going to make the whole
the whole thing free if you if you want
to come and watch these trains you know
just come on down we got a spot for you
Texas has got a lot of land he found
kind of places good Hills around it that
all the crowds could gather the big kind
of natural almost like a natural place
to see this and they they ran that the
trains line through there so so
overnight you know so the the railway
loved it like the KT is like all right
like you're gonna jam some trains
together this is gonna be a big
promotional event they booked it like
four or five months out they started
started working on it oh the kicker here
was you know he goes from from this
pasture agent like big tent promoter
extraordinaire and he they said well
this is a great idea we're just gonna
name the town right after you so they
called they called it crush Texas and it
was a city for a day all of one day and
they sold these tickets tickets from
from Dallas to crush Texas and her
crushes it was located right in outside
of West Texas which it sounds like a
direction but West Texas is actually a
town and it's in between Austin and
Dallas if you're thinking about that so
the idea was we're not gonna make money
on the actual event we're gonna make
money on all the ticket sales and so
they sold a lot of tickets they sold so
many tickets that it was the largest
exhibition in the state of Texas that it
ever happened and 40,000 people the
estimates range from 30 to 50,000 but a
lot of people think it was about 40,000
people came to crush Texas to watch this
whole thing go down
so crush you know put on his put on his
hat and he said alright well what are we
gonna do to make this happen I you know
it's gonna be kind of rowdy I mean
40,000 people even today like that's
like RSA sized event right so like
that's a big event so we're gonna need
some police officers and they built a
makeshift jail they drilled a bunch of
water wells
to help make sure no one no one got you
know dehydrated or anything brought in
water tankers from outside brought in
some concessions some lemonade stands
from Dallas I think ten of those were
brought in from from a guy up there
preachers and politicians descended on
there and there was a Midway that had
games cigars as a carnival all sorts of
thing big festival of festivity so on
the business model didn't stop there so
he had he had the ticket revenue he had
the concession revenue and then
now he added advertising revenue these
are the two trains that he was gonna jam
together he he you can see over there on
the far on the far right-hand side there
are some advertisements on those we
can't see it too clearly but he started
selling banner ads you know if we were
to think about it in in our parlance
right and crush was concerned about
safety
he understood like this is this is a
thing where people could get hurt not
just from getting dehydrated and
standing out there watching these trains
get jammed together but you know boilers
explode this is a shot for the train
engine in the 1850s where just a boiler
exploded and at that point you may be
thinking well what's you know what's
going on here this is a all the pipes
kind of running vertically they kind of
convey all the steam that steam gets
turned in to power to push the wheels
and this would just happen sometimes
like you're just driving down the down
the you know on your way and here's some
clunk clunks and then all of a sudden
the the train explodes and now you're
and now you're in a kind of a dire
situation so it's not like the idea of
boilers exploding or novel or new like
crushed new to think about that so we
had engineers come and look at the
boilers and they said yeah these look
good he laid four miles of track cuz he
also didn't want like the catastrophe to
spread outside of the two engines he
didn't want it to take down the train
the train tracks he wanted to be able to
still have service to and from the event
so he they laid four miles of brand-new
track that they were gonna run these
trains together at he kept the crowd
back at 200 yards
he let the press come in a little closer
at a hundred yards to get better photos
and and then word got out about this
event and so the you know he went to a
big promoting type type role and Edison
Thomas Edison wanted to film it
he had a Kinetoscope this is the device
they used to display it but they took a
kinetograph they're not Edison himself
but one of his one of his students I
think or his one of his employees and so
on on the fourth of four p.m. on
September 15th in 1896 the trains were
released to come together
one of the reporters that was on the
scene they said the rumble of the two
trains faint and far off at first it
would faint and far off at first but
growing nearer and more distinct with
each fleeting second it was like the
gathering force of a cyclone and they
captured this image right before the the
trains you know collided and it's a it's
a pretty great image considering the
technology of the day right and you see
this and so and they collided at a speed
between 90 miles an hour and 120 miles
an hour the estimates are kind of range
on that and and it was a big explosion
really big and but one second right
after that initial explosion there was a
subsequent spot explosion and both of
the boilers and both engines also
exploded and that was we showed a
picture of the boiler in like real life
but here it is a diagram of it and it
was common for like if you got any
cracks on the you know along the walls
or in the welds or if there was any rust
inside and so as I started researching
this I started kind of geeking I was
like well how do boilers explode well
you know how did this all work right and
so you you kind of go down the process
but you see this is actually the the
boilers this is not just the train you
know exploding this is the the boilers
exploding now propelling all sorts of
straddle across the sky and it was is
the steam and the iron and the wood just
filled the sky and it started to rain
down on all the crowds of course they're
Texans so after the dust settled they
wanted to go get a souvenir so then they
hey they rushed the the scene of the
accident not to be held back and then
they also got burned from that because
it was still hot you know
so injuries were sustained on all sides
and the there's restroom it's about four
people that died of the other aftermath
and followed from this crush was fired
widespread injuries during the incident
then you know more injuries after the
incident after everybody's trying to
collect their their souvenir
crush Texas was immediately shut down
the Katie lawyers and Representatives
were brought in and they they started to
work out the settlements with everybody
and get all the details done this is a
couple days later when they say all
right we gotta pull up the tracks and
now when you go there there's there's
nothing there like there's nothing in
the field and we have the sign and I
think things in the 80s they had to sign
out kind of in the middle of nowhere
where the site actually was right out of
the outside of the eye 35 in Texas but
then they ended up moving it into the
town of West because like no one ever
actually went out there it's still just
a big empty field so this is uh this is
what we've been left with so more
fallout happened in the days the days
following so crush later was rehired by
the Katie and he worked there for forty
four more years so the the firing didn't
stick because it turned out that no one
really blamed him for it and it was just
sort of a more of a move a political
move to cover their their bases there
for the Train and and after this
happened it was actually deemed as a
success
oddly enough demolition derby via trains
started become a national phenomenon
hundreds of other City would think like
okay cool they're gonna say hey guys
stop stop doing that like stop ramming
trains together but no they they decided
like no we're gonna keep keep this up
but in the events the the hundred of
events that happened post crush all the
boilers held so it's not like it was a
crazy idea to do this in the first place
like that you know it's it was possible
to do this without having mass chaos and
death and and all that so alright in all
this what can we learn what is it these
are some things that I took away from it
first off like we we have Cronos in
tourism which you know we think that our
generation and our time were smarter you
know because when I first started
reading this and started going through
this I read about it like oh yeah like
why you know why would you why would you
do this like that's a bad idea also
engineering is hard right we we think
that that you know they obviously got
the engineering right to get the
the crash happen in the right spot where
everybody could view it the
photographers could take the pictures
they could try to try to video it for
the first time which it would have been
if we're if the video had to survive
which it didn't for medicine it would be
the first like special effect ever
recorded also blame is really easy like
you can you know just fire somebody or
you can sort of you know use that as an
option to to deal with the problems but
it's not really a fair a fair way to
deal with it and it also taught me like
root causes a myth like who is the main
cause for this like was it was it crush
was that the the people at the the KT
who approved the whole event was that
the engineers who evaluated the you know
the engines to say that they were safe
to do the crash the or was a part of
society like wanting to see this kind of
thing it's hard to hard analyze in this
sort of situation who really would do
that who is really at fault in that
scenario and when you're thinking of
socio-economic and socio technical
systems like that that sort of overlays
and over maps to that so I also believe
that like breaches and failures or
accidents or whatever that doesn't stop
business and we saw that like they
continued to keep on going and and have
some progress where they where they're
able to have a lot more of these type of
events later on and the late 1800s and
be successful and also the last thing I
came away from this is that
experimentation and learning are
critical for us and if you could they
could have done some sort of smaller
scale experiments like that would have
been a better better play there okay
cool well yeh trains right okay yeah
well okay I was hoping that would be
funnier cool so dev sack ops well where
does this all fit in with dev psych ops
and like we have all these learnings we
can think about this event that happened
you know 100 years ago hundred 23 years
ago but what does that really mean for
us what does that mean for us today how
do we think about this thing that we're
left with they were now dealing and
talking about called dev sec ops and I
think that I'd like to in the in the
words of my good friend
Josh Zimmerman and his DevOps deep
thoughts I thought I'd like to to think
about what dev psych ops means maybe in
order to understand dev Sec ops we have
to look at the word itself basically
it's made up of three separate words de
Vie Seco and well what are those words
mean it's a mystery and that's why so is
dev Sec ops and so we're left with it
and we're thinking why do we have this
what does this mean well first I think
we could look at DevOps and understand
how we got there and that might inform
us like why we think dev psych ops is
important and and how we can live with
it so this is gonna be a real special
time for us first we had the cloud and
it was great and we saw it and we loved
it and the data it just got so big and
we were thinking this is awesome you
know now and now our new OSI model is
really a lot easier to understand which
I am this is my favorite part of it all
because I was really always struggling
before and then we have this thing
called service that came out that let us
move our our consumption and and payment
closer to what we're actually using Tom
lemon Shelly says this he says DevOps is
inevitable result of needing to do
efficient operations in a distributed
computing and cloud environment so when
we have a single person managing ten and
hundreds of computers is fine are you
doing thousands not so fine you need
something different but Damien Edwards
always reminds us that DevOps is not a
technical problem DevOps is a business
problem I like to think of it as a
pistol an epistemological breakthrough
where you join two to despaired groups
of people around a common problem
DevOps was needed to fix also the
inevitable distribution of labor that we
often experience where you'd have ten
developers to one operation person and I
also think that you know DevOps is just
another way point you can think of it
this way is it's just another way point
on the journey of agile across the
business and and to find value okay fine
maybe you're convinced maybe not but
that's what that's what DevOps is but
why do we need devstack ops why is it
important and I asked myself the same
question I
yeah this is just going to get out of
control like we're gonna be stuck with
this this scenario and it's not going to
be great for us but a little bit of
empathy also kicked in like figuring
that security itself is finding itself
security it's finding itself in the same
position that operations did in the
early movement of DevOps so for every
100 developers you'd have ten operations
to one security person there's a natural
satellizer that happens whenever you do
this people are throwing things over the
wall and and security like operations
really struggles to provide value and
many organizations this book Steve below
van that he wrote it's called thinking
security and there's two two quotes that
I like almost like to always use in any
presentation I give and this is one of
them he says companies are spending a
great deal on security but we read a
massive computer related attacks clearly
something is wrong and the root of the
problem is twofold
we're protecting the wrong things and
we're hurting productivity in the
process does that bother anybody here
does that does that hit home yeah right
it's like we're we're not stopping the
problem the breaches continue to get
worse and we're slowing everything down
like in the business doesn't always see
security is on their side the other one
that I like is Michael's a loose Keys
book the tangled web in it in in the
first chapter first second chapter he
walks through a history of computing and
says it kind of goes through like in
there and where security was in the 50s
60s 70s 80s 90s but in the 90s we kind
of hit this speed bump and we have this
this quote he says security by risk
assessment introduces a dangerous
fallacy that structured inadequacy is
almost as good as adequacy and that
underfunded security efforts plus risk
management are just about as good as
properly funded security work and I read
this quote many years ago and it's
always stuck with me as just a like we
don't want to do that we actually want
to do good engineering work we don't we
just want to just buy insurance policies
or do actuarial duties to deal with our
problems but that's what we're often
left doing last year late last year sans
came out with a report for the deficit
cops survey and it said engineering
while engineering
are busily deploying leading-edge
technology security teams are focused on
fighting yesterday's battles does that
hit home with anybody I kind of yeah
yeah and that that happens right and I
know people that go in on security
engagements or just engagements for
consulting and they're like other
they're talking to kubernetes well what
do you do for security they're like we
don't tell the security people about our
kubernetes deployment they're like why
it's like because they'll get it all up
in our business and like we don't want
that right and it's like okay that's a
real problem and I think it's because
one of the things we often feel with
security is that many security teams
work with this world view where their
goal is to inhibit change as much as
possible and it's kind of reasonable I
mean we're dealing with or it's it's
reasonable to see why we need this right
we have new technology that's coming
about and we have an increased
organization focus on software delivery
and I think that's why we really need
dev suck-ups like we're trying to
produce at a faster speed and we have a
lot more technology involved and so we
need something different and so this is
where I think that we need to think of
this new breed this this person as the
dev setup and I'd like to talk like what
I think the dev setup is talk through a
framework that I've worked on for that
but it's not a tool it's not you can't
buy it over in the expo hall and I mean
I know some people would convince you
otherwise but you can't buy it over
there it's not a CIC D pipeline that
maybe has some security tools you know
jammed in there and you know it is
something that is that we become and
it's something that we are that we are
dealing with as we kind of wrestle with
the idea of deficit gaps and I like to
say it's an inclusive person
participating the movement of security
into DevOps so I have this framework
that I've been working on it's that it's
the measure framework and we're gonna
punch through each of these and I don't
want you to take this as like you have
to be doing all all seven of these to be
you know fully like devstack ops not not
even all of them will fit but in the
spirit of like John Willis or John
Willis and Damon Edwards when they
came out with the cams model which is
the culture automation measurement and
sharing and then later clams because
they added lean in there I wanted to
give us a way to think about how dev
sack ops works how we can sort of
rationalize it when we're dealing with
in our business make business cases for
it and and put effort and engineering
behind different areas of our of our
software delivery and development so
what does measure mean it means maker
driven experimenting automating and
safety aware unrestrained sharing rugged
izing and empathy all righty you guys
ready yeah okay thought that'd be more
exciting so we'll see we'll just that's
good you know it's the afternoon and all
that stuff and I already gave you the
slides here like I know where you're
going at this so okay
all right so maker driven let's let's
kind of punch through a few things on
this all right so first we're software
engineers who specialize in a specific
discipline security that means one thing
that means that security must be able to
write code and I've said this before at
a conference and then I got like a lot
of hate messages on Twitter about it and
in the end I sort of and so if you if
you're hoping to to do that like that's
great take a picture of it put it on
Twitter say the wicked says security
must be able to write code and I'll be
dealing with that for like months to
come appreciate it thanks but we could
really think about what it really means
like you're in the process of delivering
software you're in you're you're you're
you're in the world of software and you
don't know how to actually like create
software to be a part of the process of
writing software like that should be
concerning like security should know how
to be a part of this operations had to
do the same thing operations used to say
well I just run the internet server and
I don't deal with any other problems or
I just run the you know the Tomcat or
whatever but all that stuff had to break
down I'm not saying security needs to
lead the process I'm not saying like
Security's main job is to write code but
being part of the software delivery
process that's really important and I
don't know why this is a hot take in our
industry but it seems to be and we'll
see and maybe in five years I'll be
wrong but I think
in five years I won't be if you try to
get a job like one of those like
startups or not going to startups like
any any security job right now that's
like dev SEC Ops like they're gonna
expect you to write code right I mean
that seems pretty pretty reasonable and
there's a lot of resources available
today yeah these are my two favorite
books on writing code that were that I
don't leave these keep these on the
right on the desk so in the end like we
have to think about that we have to
internalize this is like security as
part of making like we're a part of the
building of the stuff and rardy we're
already somewhat developers operations
was like yeah you know I do already kind
of know a lot of yeah MLAT well I guess
his other stuff back then but I'm
dealing with all this kind of code like
stuff and security is already using
those those DSL zazz well like we're
dealing with like writing those regex
rules by trial and error okay you
haven't been you haven't lived that or
you're like I don't want to live that
anymore so but but the part is the the
point is is that the security team has
to participate in in the software
delivery process this is also an empathy
building exercise because it provides
you familiarity with the tools and be
able to move up and down the pipeline
you're able to shift left and shift
right and all that all that sort of
stuff but you're able to participate in
that process another thing that I'll say
is part of being being maker driven is
it to realize that a bug is a bug as a
bug like to internalize that and
understand that when we think about
security bugs they're just regular bugs
that can be exploited and I know a DJ
ashleen has a lot of comments right now
on defect density and I'm not even going
to talk about the importance of it or
how maybe it's a misleading metric or
any of that sort of stuff but I will
think I do want you to think about this
all computer science papers that they
kind of talk about defect density or
errors per lines of code and all that
sort of stuff
the studies range from like half to ten
per thousand line of code the important
part is that defect density is never
zero defect density is never zero and
now whenever I'm dealing with like all
my framework and
dependencies and all the stuff that it
gets bundled into my software the 500
lines of code are a thousand lines of
code that I write can easily turn into
you know four hundred thousand lines of
code five hundred thousand lines of code
okay so my hot take on all that is that
we just can't train developers we can't
just say well we're just gonna put you
through the annual the annual training
and like you're gonna be you know good
to go
you know how good luck with that and we
can't train humans we can't train
developers to write secure code not
because developers are stupid or not
because the you know the training
doesn't exist or we didn't buy the right
product it's because you can't teach
humans to write code that doesn't have
errors we've been trying to for a long
time and there's there's no way to do it
so instead I think we should focus on
the ways that developers use to deliver
a code that is like less error-prone and
more resilient defaults so they do
test-driven development behavior driven
development they put meaningful comments
in their commits or in their in the code
they think of like code smells and
patterns and refactoring and
instrumentation and observability and
they work with the they work in ways
that that security could easily fit our
tooling and our processes into that
right okay so where were we left with
this the agile application security book
says the goal should be to come up with
a set of tests an automated test that
probe and check security configurations
and runtime system behavior for security
features that will execute every time
the system is built and every time it is
deployed so all right that's that's
that's how we can think about it my last
point on this this measure piece is that
security is inherently connected with
quality the the dev sec ops community
survey in 2019 found that one in four
developers believe that security is
synonymous with quality and we think
that's going to continue to grow over
time like that is one of those things
that people believe about their software
and they want to have high quality
software so being maker driven means to
see security as part of engineering view
quality as a way to bring security in
and use code and not vendors to solve
problems don't tell people in the expo
hall that I said that last bit okay so
expert
experimenting and and how we can learn
from our experiments so what are some
benefits that we can have from from
doing experiments they can be measured
and repeatable there we get results
based on our needs we have actual
outcomes and and we can look at I like
Erin's quote I work with their and Erin
Reinhardt he says this security
incidents are not effective measures of
detection because at that point it's
already too late so what if you're able
to sort of do some experimentation and
learn like what are some common causes
or common problems you have Shanon Lisa
and I gave this presentation at RSA and
2019 and some research that she did was
taking the Olas top ten and moving this
across that's the blue dots there and
then breaking it down into a tech attack
vector or attack of types of attackers
and it's split up there with with
scanners paid noise and then advanced
adversaries mean different colors the
point is that you kind of got to watch
the whole talk and it's a it she really
is able to build all that out for you
but what your system actually
experiences is different from what we
will be predict with the Olas top ten
and it's different by your vertical by
your company business unit so that's
something that's worth thinking about
and understanding what am I actually
being attacked with okay so and so yeah
so no the no the most likely attacks and
how to measure abuse and misuse Zane
Lackey over at signal sciences he says
we can't seed home-field advantage and I
like that because a lot of times the
security would say well you can't you
can't make a perfectly secure system
it's like well maybe not but I know my
system better than anybody else right at
least could way better than the
attackers good so why can't I actually
understand it a little more further so
but experimenting necessitates that we
understand our steady state so I think
there's a couple resources for you any
of the stuff that Shannon leads does her
Twitter handles Deb psych ops and
there's a talk which is very similar to
that slide that I showed for 2019 RSA
that's hooked in there as well
so all right a automation all right this
is the the the piece that I think is
pretty interesting to a lot of us is
what we think about when we start
thinking about
devstack ops we think about the pipeline
this also come from that from that Deb
psych ops survey but you can break it up
to all the phases of the pipeline and
you can see the those without a DevOps
practice there's the kind of the orangie
looking red color on there for you and
those are those are much lower than
people that have implemented
applications security practices which is
then they are like they're kind of
called the DevOps elite and they're like
that purpley blue color but I was really
just encouraged across the way like all
a lot of the phases of the pipeline
people are implementing security tooling
and security testing if you attended
Derek's talk you could see that like
survey data versus like reality and code
may not be as great as great as you
think so you might want to hit him up
for some things on the slides for for
that for that talk but I also thought it
was cool like web application firewalls
container applications security open
source governance static application
analysis dynamic application analysis
these are tools that we've had for most
of them for a fairly long amount of time
and we see that those are DevOps elite
practices far in a way have them
installed across in larger usage across
the organization all right so also with
automating is we can think about how how
much we deliver how often we how often
we deliver how security plays in inside
of that just humble in his book
continuous delivery says continuous
delivery is how little you can deploy at
any one time I have to think about this
as cycle time and we like to we need to
optimize for for total cycle time and
that means from time code commit to like
running and production you want that to
be as small as possible a lot of people
will recommend like the coffee tests of
like if it takes longer than five
minutes to go from code commit to
running in production you might need a
refactor you need to include your
security tests in that as well there's a
great talk yesterday about the on the
pipeline and how to how to do that and
like how you can fork out like
long-running jobs and things like that
but whenever I was over at signal
Sciences we did 15,000 deploys in three
and a half years
and and you know a fairly small team
fairly small start-up but we were moving
quite rapidly it's because we constantly
were always optimizing for for total
cycle time we would have meetings
already to come in and be like all right
here's the build it's like six minutes
today like how can we get this to go
faster and so everybody would have to
like you know count off for like what
they're doing and and we would look at
the security test along with everything
else and it wasn't the answer to drop
them it was like maybe run them in at
different cadence run them in a
non-blocking mode maybe move them to the
deployment system which we did did as
well but putting security in the
pipeline you know you can you can start
kind of small right you can do I mean I
guess SCA is not that small but you can
put language linters you can do some
like get out and stuff putting some
scanners in there using gauntlet putting
monitoring and telemetry in there those
are some ideas for you there's there's
been a lot of great talks at this
conference already about how to do a lot
of that stuff but we're now we're able
to treat deploys as standard routine
changes that have been pre-approved by
management and they don't require this
heavyweight change approval board or
anything like that so that's really
refreshing and that means like security
can now like unlock that whole like
going fast part right maybe we're not
maybe we may or may not be like stopping
all the breaches but at least we can
unblock the business and hopefully we
will like bring down some of the some of
the breaches as well so I have two
courses that I've written on this topic
one is dev sack ops building the secure
continuous delivery pipeline over on
LinkedIn learning and the other one is
an automated security testing which is
more of a deep dive into the actual code
side but if you're interested in those
go check it out or hit me up I might be
able to get you like free access to it
alright alright the next one here asks
safety aware do we understand like the
difference between simple and complex
systems a lot of times we are our human
brains will often try to take a complex
system and we try to make it they could
make it a simple system when we say
simple we mean they're linear in nature
they're they're easy to predict and and
something that we're able to comprehend
in our head like it's something we're
able to keep our mental you know model
if you will and understand but complex
systems they are nonlinear in nature
they suffer from what's what can be
called a
bullwhip effect so a small change at one
end of the whip creates you know
sound sound breaking sound barrier
breaking at the other end right so so
completely different results can happen
out of the system they're unpredictable
in nature and there's no mental model
available form so with all this like we
we like to abstract complexity away and
this is something we do you know in code
and frameworks and other things like
that but we do it with we try to you
know think of human beings like we have
another mental model or the way we deal
with other people we do there's a
society psychological issues we do it
because we can't handle all the
cognitive load of keeping it all
straight in our head at any one time and
so and we deal with that same problem
through software and we just add another
layer of abstraction right like that's
always the the quickest way to solve a
problem it's like I bet some yeah mold
might fix that I thought that one would
be funnier so good we're two for two
great who do you maybe Evan burned
enough by M oh I don't know but so as we
think about complex systems then we now
have to think if we don't actually
understand the system in any sort of
real way why is it do we think that we
can arrive at a root cause in a failure
type mode and so I think root cause
specifically in a complex system as a
myth because we lack the full picture
complex systems aren't linear this is
part of our blame culture that we that
we live in you can think about our
example with with William crush right
it's like and you're fired it's like
well you know at first blush like that
seemed like a good idea but later it's
like well I mean you know all the steps
were taken you know who may be somebody
else should have been fired right it
also lacks the context and forgets the
organizational decisions around the the
whole the whole event as it happens it
really puts a focus on the specific you
know the two trainings crashing into
each other the explosion rather than the
the whole situation and kind of lead-up
to the whole event and how it all
unfolded together right
and Sidney Dekker has a great book
called drift into failure and he has
this quote he says drifting into failure
is a gradual incremental decline into
disaster driven by environmental
pressure unruly technology and social
processes that normalize growing risk no
organization is exempt from drifting
into failure we can think about the
Boeing 737 max we can think about how
like you know now we're we have this the
MCAS it's it commands the trim so the
pilots don't have to worry about it for
like a larger airplane the thing is the
mcs is just software like the software
was doing all this without the pilots
like really being able to detect what
was doing what was going on and they
were being told you know like the
software was fighting the pilots like
silently and the the pilots were having
to deal with this all this information
in a context where they were told that
everything is like a normal you know
Boeing 737 and it was and it I don't
even research this or seen any of these
the info on this but the crashes were
happening they're like three to five
minutes before after the planes takeoff
something like that so you were putting
your these your operators in a
high-speed decision-making environment
in a very an up-tempo environment where
they have to figure out what's going on
and all the software is telling them
that everything is fine and software is
eating the world and taking over our
systems so we're you know our physical
systems as well so now we're living in
this complex environment where we're
dealing with this and Sidney Decker's
quote goes on to sir he goes on to say
something else about complexity says the
growth of complexity in society has
gotten ahead of our understanding of how
complex systems work and how they fail
so it's kind of concerning but I was
like I don't know maybe oh here I'll
pull down to a server list app and I was
like oh that's that's cool I can
understand that I get it like where's my
three-tier web app right it's like like
now at least I could like put that in my
brain and figure out like yeah the
blinky lights on the database are not
good like it's like things aren't
working in your web app you're like I
have no idea and this was whenever I
went and downloaded this is like an easy
you know getting started guide of like
you know how to use lamb
stuff like okay cool I think my friend
Matt Stein says he's like it's becoming
clear to me now
software probably a mistake I don't know
exactly what he was talking about but I
like to think he's talking about this so
we were leaving the operations and the
security team we're putting all this
burden on them to rationalize our system
models and to keep all this in their
heads so that is not good and we have to
think about our failures as a system
problem because we don't have enough
safety margin and that's a quote from
agent Cockroft and and we have to also
reckon with this with this fact that now
we're dealing with with systems or
complex there they can they think they
fail it's just that part of their nature
and Sidney Decker says failure is an
inevitable byproduct of a complex
systems normal functioning like it's an
inescapable thing so how does security
fit in all this well security can be
part of the story of adding safety
margin in we can add telemetry and
instrumentation in we can participate in
blameless retros by most retrospectives
or post mortems or however you think
about that but specifically on the
blameless side of things and and I have
some more stuff in the empathy section
to talk about that later but if you're
interested in any of this so like you're
kind of peaked there like okay the
safety stuff like sounds oddly familiar
and oddly scary to the stuff that I deal
with in security here's some here's some
links for you I guess the the text there
maybe be hard to read but check these
out there is a human error video series
that Aaron Reinhart turned me on to by
Sidney Decker that I think is like
really great and then if you don't have
any if you only have time to do one
thing or read one thing at the very
bottom there's Richard cooks paper it's
a called how complex systems fail it's
pretty short Richard cook is a medical
doctor and he he wrote this this this
thing about how complex systems the
human body failed but when you read it
as an IT person you're like holy smokes
like that sounds exactly like the stuff
that I deal with on a day-to-day basis
and now Richard cook goes around
speaking on this and he'll speak at a
lot of IT conferences nowadays because
of kind of so much overlap and so much
so much learning that we've gotten out
of that okay well let's move long so
let's talk about unrestrained sharing
unrestrained sharing is is something
that may feel a little weird to security
but Patrick Dubois when he first founded
DevOps and he first kicked it off I
think is like 2011 or 2012 he did a
enterprise and DevOps work in the
enterprise and and he did a whole I
think was a cutter IT Journal on this
but one of his quotes is that culture is
the most important aspect to DevOps
succeeding in the enterprise and if you
go back in time and you were like to ask
anybody in DevOps like what is DevOps
especially in like 2010 or 2011 they
would just say it is a cultural movement
you know stop right and then you're like
well that's that's not gonna do it but
they were so worried about like people
taking DevOps and then equating that
with some sort of software or tooling or
job title or something like that
eventually we did all those things
because we're humans and that's what we
do and they they you know all of the
original DevOps OGIS were like that's
that's going to happen so we we don't
want to do that but it's it's gone ahead
and happen anyways but I do still
believe that we originally focused on
culture for the right reason and we
still need to continue to keep that as a
heartbeat for for DevOps because Deb
psych ops is just an extension of DevOps
we need to think about that as we kind
of move forward rich Smith he says
former security director over at Etsy he
says the security team who embraces
openness about what it does and why
spreads understanding so under strain
Colten australian sharing affects our
culture but it goes against a lot of our
standard operation operating procedures
a lot of times I think that you'll feel
that it'll feel uncomfortable to you to
share but sharing naturally breaks down
silos you know if you like if you it's
like Oh only the security team is
allowed to log into this one security
tool like developers should never have
you know information about this because
you know cloak-and-dagger type stuff
well like that's probably wrong if you
have thinking like that you need to try
to come up with ways to maybe sanitize
some of the data or whatever but you got
to figure out ways to create sharing
across those groups for keys that I
think are important for culture are
having a mutual understanding having
shared
language having shared views putting
collaborative tooling in place and and
as those things kind of develop you
start building culture that is really
useful I like the deaf suck-up survey
because one of the questions that
they're asking developers like hey what
do you think about just you know
security or and then they were trying to
going back and forth on this but one of
the answers was you know we don't even
really know what like security wants
from us like we have no idea what they
want us to do and and it didn't matter
if they were a DevOps practice or
immature and their DevOps practice they
were just like you know flat out like a
fifth of them are just like confused
like we security has not brought them in
in the process so I think security
shares through making stuff the
invisible stuff visible adding security
observability finding ways to put in
api's or web hooks or dev tooling or any
of that sort of stuff and you can't
leave out the auditors which is I know
it's really tempting to do sorry if
there's any auditors in the room but I
think it's important there's a project
that we started working on I guess about
a year and a half two years ago called
dear auditor and it's over at dear audit
org and this is a love letter from dev
ops to auditors and in it we we we
apologize which sometimes you have to do
and we said hey we started this whole
DevOps thing and we didn't bring the
auditors around because I don't anybody
go through like an audit or compliance
thing you're like you start talking and
the auditors like mmm that is not gonna
work you know and you're like we have a
huge disconnect here so so I've
experienced that and so we built this
and then also associated with this is a
DevOps controls matric matrix so if you
want it's open source
check it out we're still working on it
so putting some stuff stuff together on
this but yeah okay so some resources for
under strange sharing I think the
Phoenix project book if you haven't read
it I know it's kind of cannon now but
definitely check that out that book the
agile applications security book has
some as some context on on this as well
and then dear auditor I think is a great
resource or I think it could be a great
resource if we can kind of get more work
behind it
okay let's talk ruggedized ation what do
we mean about ruggedized ation
it is it is it is running everywhere
yeah so I think one thing like the one
way we build something that's rugged is
by like knowing what we have which is
kind of a novel concept right so like we
have our build materials and so we we
get to know what is inside of our
software another thing that you can
think about for rugged or rugged ization
of software is that you know we favor
short-lived systems the old saying of
cattle not pets
although I've heard some people tell me
they don't they don't appreciate that
and there's some other ways we could
think about it but like I don't know but
Sunil you he has the the Daiya framework
and he's working on a paper and I'm not
sure if it's out yet or not but he's
he's it's a it's proving that just by
having these three attributes in your
system your your by by the very nature
mathematically more secure so if it's
distributed immutable in ephemeral if
you have those three things in in any
combination you are you're gonna be more
secure so it's a pretty cool pretty cool
research and really interesting so as
that comes out or kind of be looking for
it as you can find it
but where is recognization going like we
can we can talk about other other types
of stuff but I think there's two key
areas where I believe rugged ization is
happening and we're gonna see this grow
over the next year first I think
deception this is you know this we I
know we have like all the honey pots and
all that stuff like ten years ago
and but I see people really like
industry leading firms that are that are
working on doing deception tactics that
are making a huge difference they're
putting honey pits and tar pits and man
traps and all sorts of stuff it's simple
to get started you can like just you
know puts you know spoof out some you
know some hidden htpb feels or something
like that and see if those get called
and then you can fly a get some good
projects on this honey pie is an open
source one deception logic is a friend
of Mines companies trying to get off the
ground so it's kind of cool but but
thinking through like how do we build
better deception into our systems as
ways we can get security to limit ori
and Instrumentation out and to the
developers and we can sort of play that
out so the other piece that I think is
also chaos engineering which is someone
where we've kind of
started with this whole talk and and
we've talked about where that sort of
fits in but we're moving from this
disaster recovery belief system to now
we're moving into chaos engineering and
then overall like we're trying to build
overall resiliency and Adrian Cockcroft
has a great quote on that Michael
Nygaard so if you need a primer to chaos
engineering and you're like you can't
wait until the the new O'Reilly book
comes out in a few months there's a
there's a great book called release it
but you have to get the second edition
if you want to if you want to check it
out because the out of the chaos
engineering in the second edition but
it's by Michael Nygaard he has this
quote he says chaos engineering is
empirical rather than formal we don't
use models to understand what the system
should do we run experiments and then we
learn what it does Erin Reinhardt my
buddy says the security discipline of
chaos experimentation is done in order
to build confidence in the system's
ability to defend against malicious
conditions and so that's what that's
what chaos engineering is trying to do
we're trying to experiment we're trying
to run run these experiments that span
both engineering and security a lot of
places will put it into a commando
opt-out type scenario but you make
valuable learning and like it's all
about the learning you're not trying to
just blow stuff up and break stuff in
production which you know some of the
marketing material will come out on that
but what we're really trying to do is
figure out our system operates like this
today and we get a more clear picture of
that and we build these experiments that
are controlled they have a controlled
blast radius and it helps prove out like
if our mental model and our
understanding of the system is true
today and then like whenever that
experiments gets run again later is it
still true here's some resources on this
there's a Aaron stock at RSA there's the
principles of chaos there's the release
it book and then Phillip Maddux and herb
Todd both have great talks on deception
so feel free to check those out if you
can it's like you're like I didn't know
I was gonna get all this homework so but
you know I find that as good oh let's go
back to the wall here alright so when I
think of all the arguments this is oh
and I have had I realize how silly most
of them were and it makes me wonder why
he wanted to argue over such stupid
things I think I'll go ask him
this is a problem in our industry how
did you want to picture that you could
see that this is problem in our industry
we're we're kind of like always a war
and and against each other
and who's ever had this situation where
maybe not you cuz you're you know right
ma you're a tent you're at global OPSEC
DC so you're right minded individual but
who says oh those stupid developers
anybody our friend that ever says that
yeah it's ok nobody wants to admit it
it's ok if you've said it too it happens
right but sometimes we'll say like those
stupid developers just in a real
Cavalier type manner and then I've had
developers tell me they're like oh you
security people you just want us to
power off the machine and unplug them
and just like you know like and I'm like
wow so you think that I don't understand
where my paychecks come from because
like I know if we did that long enough
like we would never know you know it's
the business you know ends right but the
but developers see security is so
disconnected from the running of the
business they're like the only way
they're going to be happy is if just you
know you have you know complete you know
nihilism here right so well half the
developers say that they don't have time
to spend on security and and that's
something that they they deal with the
we've looked at this from 2017 2018 2019
the deficit cops report is always
reporting like 50 percent or 48 percent
they're in the background but developers
want to do security they just thought
you know fine that they often don't have
time and so one of the ways that as a
security person we can be helpful
especially in the apps tech world is
like hey let's not be blockers but let's
be enablers let's help you know kind of
do all these other things in the measure
framework to help us make that happen ok
well I'm going to kind of wind down here
this is the the measure framework again
and we've kind of gone through that and
if you have any so one of the things
we're doing is we're collecting stories
about devstack ops movements or
transformations or failures at
organizations and we're working on a
book for the same publisher as the dev
ops handbook over with Jean Kim but you
can share your story with us book at dev
suck-ups org and we'd be happy to
interview you kind of write up a case
study if you need us to do it
anonymously I guess we could
but we learned like I said it doesn't
have to be a pure success it could be
like yeah we tried it and then like it
didn't work like that's still really
really valid information for us
so if you have any if you want to get
the slides you can send me an email it
at wicked America IO or if you have any
questions you can hit him yet to a
wicked but no we're kind of towards into
the conference and we have a little bit
break and I asked Sean about this
earlier with the I know like Matt
tessaro's here Aaron reinhardt's here
DJ slean's here so we thought maybe we
could have a dev check op support group
down here at the front so if you have
any like questions or you need anything
like you asked me ask these these guys
they've done it alike you know large
large enterprises they've they've put
together pipelines at different places
so we'd be happy to come talk about it
we're gonna be hanging around by the
front for a little bit but but I
appreciate your time and thanks and hope
you enjoy the rest of the conference
[Applause]